今日は豚のステーキだって🐷
はじめんごめんね、あと７ヶ月がんばって！！！！
・・・
はああああああい！
こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです
皆さんポイフルというお菓子知ってますでしょうか？
空箱で申し訳ないんですけどこういうお菓子です
味がね　こう　いろいろあるんですけども
ポイポイ！たのしい元気のタネ！
なんと、コラーゲンが入っております
あのですね、ぼく、ポイフル
だぁぁぁぁぁぁいすきなんですよ♡
このサイズなんで、もうなんかおいしいし、食っても食っても止まんねえみたいな感じで
当然一箱あっても全然足りない！
てか！
無限に食える気がします
ということで今日はこちらねpoiful３万円分を準備してしまいました・・・
ふぅぅぅ～
準備してしまったものはやるしかない
今日はちょっとこの２５歳成人男性が
本気だすとpoiful何個食えるのか
と、胃袋の限界に挑戦してみたいと思います
まあ　皆さん皆さん待ってください
体に悪いとは思うじゃないですか
でもこれ、
コラーゲンが入ってるんですよ
つまり、
食えば食うほど僕は
きれいになる✨
百害あって
一利無し
あ　違う違うｗ
要するに、食っても食っても良いことがあるんで、
僕は
やりますよ
ということで多分poifuiをたくさん食べようと思った人はそういないと思うんで、
あの割とこれが、あの　世界記録になると思います
まあこれを基準に皆さんもぜひ、あの、無理のない程度にやってみてはいかがでしょうか
では、よろしくおねがいします
スリー
トウー
ワン
スタートゥ！
（poifluが落ちる音）
おいひい
まあまあまあまあまあ
うまいっすよね
うまいんですけど、
あの、されどグミなんで
ちょっと噛むのに時間をください
今１５？
スタッフ）うん
いや１５でも全然いけます
目標８００で
スタッフ：はい
いや、全然余裕っすね
スタッフ）いま、７６
ううう
スタッフ）いま１００！
あと（聞き取れなかった）ですよこれを
無理でーす
あのぉ
まあ美味しいのは全然良いんですけど、
口ん中が痛いんすよねなんか
スタッフ）コーンのときとおんなじこと言ってるｗ
スタッフ）ええっ！？
まじまじまじ、ちょっと休憩
やばい　驚きを隠せない
すごいわ
スタッフ）なめてた？
なめてた！
よしじゃあおねがいします
スタッフ）はい　今、１００です
オッケー
いきます
パッ☆
スタッフ）ふふｗ
どんくらいっすか胃袋的には
いなり寿司食いたいって・・・　胃が
スタッフ）よくぞ言えましたねそんなことｗ
ブフッｗ
スタッフ）「俺はもう２度と食わない」って
あぁそうだったそうだったｗ
ｸﾞｸﾞｸﾞｴｴｴ
スタッフ：やばｗ
やばい！まじやばい！
あ”あっ
ああ”あ”あ”ーーーつつ
カハッ
ん”あ”あ”あ”あ”ーーーーーー
（ポスッ）
ホントやべーよこれ
いち
に
さん
し
ご
ろく
しち
はち
きゅう
じゅう
じゅういち
じゅうに
じゅうさん
じゅうし
じゅうよーーーん！！！
ぐはっ
４００超えると、運動すると吐き気を模様するようになります
スタッフ）ははっｗ
いち
に
さん
し
ごぅ
ろく
しち
お”あ”あ”あ”あ”ーーっ
う”う”ぇぇぇ
デュテッテッテッテ　デュテッテッテッテ
テーテテラテーテー
タラララー
テテラテーテー
テーテテ
タララターテーテー
ブパッパッパッパッ
デデデデン（迫真）
こうやって、投げてポイポイして食べるの楽しかったです
ただその楽しさにちょっと惑わされてて、
気づいたら４４８個食べていまして、
ちょっと運動したのも良くなかったんですけども
ちょっと、僕の記録は４４８個でした
ちなみにあれ投げて食べる記録は
えー、１４が僕の記録です
どうだい！